good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i am very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2021 2022
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the
college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the national institutes of general
medical sciences this year's theme is
ethical challenges of artificial
intelligence and biomedicine where every
friday we enjoy presentations from
leading thinkers about the promise
opportunities and hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical
sciences selected participants in our
biomedical data science innovation lab
program will leverage these
presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person grant project
development workshop to be held here in
june in charlottesville virginia
today i am delighted to welcome not one
but two speakers dr sally ann keller and
dr stephanie ship from the uva
biocomplexity institute here at the
university of virginia sally ann keller
is a distinguished professor in
biocomplexity the director of the social
and decision analytics division of the
biocomplexity institute and professor of
public health sciences her areas of
expertise are social and decision
informatics statistical underpinnings of
data science and data access and
confidentiality she is a leading voice
in creating the science of all data and
advancing this research across
disciplines to benefit society stephanie
shipp is deputy director and professor
of the social and decision analytics
division
her areas of expertise are economic
policy analysis and evaluation her work
spans topics related to the science of
data science community analytics and
ethics she is a leading and engaging
person in projects at the local state
and federal levels
to assess data quality and
use of new and traditional data sources
to advance the public good
in continuing our 2021-2022 biomedical
data science
seminar series theme sally and
stephanie's lecture today is entitled
data acumen in action
sally and stephanie will drive home the
idea that data science is the
quintessential translational research
field that starts at the point of
translation the real problem to be
solved it involves many stakeholders
across fields of practice and lends
itself to team science consequently data
science has evolved into a powerful
transdisciplinary endeavor and doing
public oriented data science has
revealed that many of the consumers in
this research do not have sufficient
data acumen and thus can be overwhelmed
with how to use data-driven insights
sally and stephanie will rightly note
that it's unrealistic to think that most
decision makers are data scientists and
so we have a lot of work to do in
training them because even with domain
knowledge some literacy and data science
remains useful
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube and
if you are watching on youtube today
thank you so much for joining us our
specially selected
2021-2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for
sally and stephanie via the chat feature
in their zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of their lecture and with that sally and
stephanie welcome we are so excited to
hear from you today
thank you jack um this is sally i'm
going to start um and i'll be handing
off to stephanie about midway through
the presentation i thought i would start
today by just sharing with you a little
bit about the biocomplexity institute at
university of virginia it's a very
unique organization it's a freestanding
research institute within the university
um it's reporting lines like
the deans of schools is directly to the
provost
and the span of research in this
institute is really exciting it
ranges from mathematical biocomplexity
theoretical mathematics around omics
genomics sequencing what we might have
called bioinformatics of years gone by
but that really theoretical mathematical
uh level of things and then it starts to
move through
from sort of the molecular level into
other behavioral scales
into massive simulations around people
and
movements of people and places and
that's our network system science and
advanced computing division so some of
the coveted model coven modeling that
you've seen coming out of university of
virginia that's helped to support the
state of virginia uh new york city and
other places have come out of this
particular group among other things and
then as you sort of drive towards
evidence-based policy
you start to uh
engage with the research of our division
the social decision analytics division
and
because of this really strong policy
focus of our work we're actually
situated up here in northern virginia to
make sure that we wake up every morning
remembering that we're in the policy
capital of the world and that we're
keeping our eyes and our um
our eyes wide open on how we can bring
our work to bear on important public
policy
so that's us
and so now we're going to start and i
always like to start by just reminding
ourself what is data science because
this is all about data science and
and uh you know ethical issues related
to data science well what the heck is
data science anyway
um and as you know jack said we view
data science as
a science that starts at the point of
translation because it is in the context
of real problems
i like to remind people that if we don't
have a problem there's no real data
science you know ai machine learning uh
statistical methods all of these things
are tools that we use in data science
they not they are not in and of
themselves data science at least
in my opinion
um and what's really important too is to
remember that if you're going to focus
on problems problem solutions require
carefully framed questions and that will
play a role as we talk about data acumen
we have had a lot of data science
partners in our work we're in our ninth
year as a research organization
and we have
done research with sponsors from
industry from local state and federal
agencies from local governments and also
from dod most specifically the army
recently
another thing that's really important to
remember is that data science is a team
sport and there you see part of our team
and
it's really about
engaging together across disciplines
across
areas of expertise
to come together and bring the best that
you can to a particular problem
okay so let's talk about what we're
calling data acumen which may be a new
term for you
and data acumen the definition that we
like to use is the ability to make good
judgments about the use of data to
support problem solutions
let's unpack that
when we talk about use of data the first
question that should come to mind is
what the heck are data and we're going
to talk about that it's not necessarily
an obvious answer
and then this issue of supporting
problem solutions
what comes to mind there is how do you
trust the use of the results for data
informed decisions
now there are levels of data acumen
many of you in the audience are data
scientists you're trained in statistics
or computer science quantitative methods
applied math
some of
you are probably subject matter experts
that you're trained in a
particular field
um some of you may cross over between
those two things and some of you or at
least a lot of the people that we work
directly with are consumers of data
science and of these data science
applications they're neither a data
scientist you know or a particular
subject matter expert but the
information is coming to them and they
have to consume it
so you know the question is which are
you let you think about that
but when we think of helping people
become
consumers when we think of helping the
communication between data scientists
and subject matter experts
that's where trying to think about how
do you actually frame and characterize
data acumen so we can all grow more of
it
so
when we think about data acumen and when
we think about the people that we work
with on our research teams with our
sponsors
we have a set of questions that we like
to keep in the front of our mind to make
sure we're walking through as we're
working with them
and the first one is you know what is
the problem or the question that they're
trying to
uh that they're trying to address again
data science is about bringing data
together to help support a problem in a
problem solution what kinds of decisions
are they trying to make you know what
data might be out there how do you trust
it how do you help them trust it if
they're a consumer what kinds of
analysis would might be needed to
support their decisions you know what
are the ethical considerations
and then finally there is a data science
process and trying to understand that
process and where you are in that
process is important
we're going to walk through those
questions um in the context of a couple
examples the first one
is
one of the very first problems that we
worked or very first partnerships that
we
created when we started our research
group about nine years ago and this is
within arlington virginia
arlington virginia is in northern
virginia it has about 240 000 in
population it covers 26 square miles it
has a pretty low unemployment rate
and a white population of 61
so
we started working with the arlington
county government
and they had a particular problem in
question that they brought to us
the problem was
they'd been hearing about the data
revolution and data science and they
wanted to know
how can they develop data informed
situational assessment or situational
awareness that could help improve
quality of life and services in the com
in the county
and the very specific first question
came from the fire chief who really
started to understand about this data
stuff
and what he wanted to know is would it
be possible to link together the fire
ems data that
gets generated to administer fire ems
9-1-1 incidents would it be possible to
pull that data across their data systems
link it together end to end and recreate
the incidents in the data because he
felt that if you could do that that data
could be used to build an understanding
to build some analyses to help them
understand resource allocation resource
utilization and training
so
we said sure why not let's see what we
can do
so the next question that comes to mind
was what kinds of decisions was he
interested in
was he interested in
strategic decisions trying to put this
information together to help inform
things more strategically future
planning future placement of fire boxes
and fire stations
was he interested in anticipatory
decisions trying to understand what are
changes that that might occur over the
county over the coming you know
weeks months years
that might change the direction that
they go with different things or were
they looking for tactical decision
making like a real time uh
board that would tell you what's going
on in a 9-1-1 situation
well it turns out that it was the
anticipatory and strategic
area that the fire chief was interested
in they didn't really want or need help
in managing you know on the fly these
incidents what they wanted to do was to
collect them
and re-evaluate what had happened
through a corpus of data by mashing up
the 911 incident data with so
socioeconomic data
so
what data are they really talking about
and what are going to be trust issues
with these data
so that brings me to ask the question
what are data
and i like to think of data as a fact
assumed to be a matter of direct
observation in other words you need to
observe something
questions are needed to inform direct
observation so we're kind of back to
this importance of these questions that
inform our problems
and then once you have a sense of what
that direct observation is you need
measurements you need to convert that
observation into
facts and those facts are the data
well let's see what we have well today
we can observe
a tremendous amount of information
you know infrastructure environment
people
and many more boxes should be on this
chart
historically we tended to treat these
things you know kind of in siloed pieces
of information we built infrastructure
models environmental models people
models but today the exciting thing is
we can blend this all together and
really mash it up
the measurement we're talking about is
we're really talking about
identifying archival data existing data
you know not necessarily primary
collected data
but secondary sources and measurement is
about data repurposing just data
repurposing on steroids but it's
important to think about how the data
are born that you're repurposing it did
it come from a design data collection
is it administrative data
that's just out there to administer an
organization and that's going to be the
lion's share of our data for this
particular problem is it data that just
is out there you know on opportunity
data on the internet and
other places that you can scrape and
pull in and then a fourth bucket of data
that's incredibly important is
procedural data which could be the
procedure that runs the stoplight on the
on on the street or the different laws
and procedures and policies that govern
an organization it's important to know
how that interfaces in with what you're
doing
okay so here's our data
and i want you to look at the middle
flow here
to begin with the flows of events an
incident occurs 9-1-1 boom it comes in
it goes to a call center the
communication center a unit is to pet
dispatched a unit arrives at the
location
they do whatever they need to do the
incident is closed
and then there's some post-incident
reporting so that's what's happening
well there's data systems that exist
that administer every one of those steps
what doesn't exist is a magic little id
number that takes you from one data
system to the next to the next to the
next that's not how they were built and
that's not what their function
that's not what their function is
designed
for then there's also other data like
american community survey data or social
media other data that if i have
locations whether it's the housing
locations or the dispatch route i can
now start to think about how to attach
these data together so that's what we
were confronted with
and we wanted to try to recreate these
incidents so what we did
we took all those data sources and we
just started to line them up in time and
on date
to see if we could identify and now
start to trace units
through their actions and trace the
reporting through
you know connect it up with an incident
and we actually were successfully able
to do this here's a picture of where
you're seeing these data linked which
had great relevancy to police chiefs
because they also started to see their
unit utilization i can't say that it
rocks my boat but i did you know we did
this to get the data reposit to get the
data set that we needed to have all
these corpus of incidents end to end but
it turns out a simple visualization like
this
spoke volumes to the fire chiefs
so the next thing to think about when
you're thinking about data acumen is
what types of analyses
can you do or
are needed to inform the decisions that
you want to try to make so now we have
this corpus of data that we've linked
together it was no trivial task to do
that but now we have something we can
work with
well types of analyses they come in
flavors we have descriptive analyses
descriptive analytics which really
summarizes
and represents the data that you have a
great way to check did you link it
properly
data then from descriptive can be used
for explanatory studies
this might help you test causal
hypothesis
constructs theories or you might be
wanting to use it for predictive
analytics
that really helps you try to predict
something in the future
and then
the other thing that you like to do if
you can is to create
simulations possibly from the data to
help ask what if questions contrafactual
analysis of the data and information and
in our institute we spend a lot of time
building platforms that help you query
and study this
and then prescriptive analytics the sort
of the holy grail that people would like
to get to where you're really trying to
do
stochastic optimization over constraints
that are placed on predictive models
well in our example
the early thing that we did was to take
this beautiful data that we'd linked
together
and just tried to draw some early data
insights that we could feed back to the
fire chief and his folks
and the very first thing was to just
look at how much time were they spending
on call because minutes matter in this
situation
so in this particular case they could
see how their different units were
functioning and how much time they were
spending on call it's a log scale on
minutes by the way on the
vertical axis
then the next thing that they were
really interested in was what about the
response time because again minutes
matter
and particularly response time from the
different fire stations with all of the
fire stations behaving similarly or were
there certain ones where there
could perhaps uh
improve their response time and so this
was another descriptive um picture that
you see here and
you know you look at this and you don't
really see much going on because
the data are noisy
and so
you know we looked at this and thought
well okay this is still descriptive can
i take this data and now do something
explanatory with it
and that was the next step and in the
explanatory analysis it was to
disentangle the fact that we had
different kinds of incidents some were
fires some were ems some were critical
things that were going to end up at the
hospital some were you know somebody
stubbed their toe so there was a whole
different set in types of incidents
going on and different incidents lead to
different apparatus different kinds of
vehicles different kinds of equipment
that gets sent
so putting that together and developing
a statistical model that can control for
all of these things
presented a pretty different picture
back to the fire chief
now you see there's
very significant differences in response
time
by the different stations and across the
area across the county which then gave
them an opportunity to delve further
into trying to understand why that is
and what they could do about it
well what about ethical considerations
and i'm going to flip to a slightly
different example
with the fire department for that
but ethical considerations first let me
just remind you what they are and this
whole series this year that
jack and company are having is around
ethics and ethics and ai or ethics and
data science and this is just one of my
most favorite examples about why we have
to worry about ethics and you probably
many of you probably already know this
example back in 2016
when amazon went to their one day
service and they decided what parts of
different cities were they going to roll
this service out to
they looked at their data which had to
do with sales and sales volume in
different areas and they decided which
neighborhoods they would roll this out
to
and unbeknownst to them their data
analysis
completely defined the racial boundaries
in these cities
so
that was sort of an aha moment we have
to really worry about what our different
models and these are ai models in this
case what are they doing you know are
they really capturing what you want to
capture are they capturing other
features that are somewhat unintended so
really thinking through your data and
what possible
biases could exist there well we have
things to guide us
we have the
fabulous belmont report that i'm
assuming most of you are familiar with
which
lays out the foundation for
institutional review boards and the
common rule that governs research
in the united states
when it comes to
having respect for persons
beneficence and justice
and when you think of the belmont report
it's laying the framework on
what you need to be worried about
thinking about we go you know the
training if you've never taken
institutional review board training i
encourage you to do it because it
takes you through a lot of thought
processes around ethics particularly
when you're focusing on human subjects
well not all of our data are about human
subjects and not all of our focus is
necessarily human subjects and it turns
out that there's a wonderful report that
came out in 2012 but was commissioned by
the department of homeland security
that
we find interesting that's pretty
underutilized and under-recognized and
it's called the menlo report
and in this report
what they were tasked to do
was to take the belmont principles and
look at how they apply
in an information communication
technology setting
and they extended the principles to
include respect for law and public
interest
and this has a focus on research with
human harming potential so i encourage
you to look at this report it was a
great uh committee largely of pretty
well-known computer scientists that
worked on this
but it takes belmont and maps it into
this other space so between these two
reports
you can start to create the picture
of data science ethics
because data science involves both of
those aspects
and if you add to that you know some of
what you know and have learned from
ethical guidelines from professional
societies
read what experts have written around
ethical questions
you can start to think about
what are the questions and the ethical
issues you need to be worried about
during the whole
life cycle of a data science project
and we've done that and the link here
takes you to a data science ethics
checklist that we've created
that is a living document
for us during the course of our projects
where we're continually revisiting these
issues and at each stage of the data
science process
we're asking questions and we're asking
questions around ethics around you know
what
are these data actually representing
who's being missed what are the biases
as i'm developing my methods and
algorithms you know where are the biases
in those
uh different methods as well
well back to our
fire department
this is a slightly different um example
because i think it highlights the
ethical issues uh quite well
in this particular case the fire chief
another question that he came to us with
he said you know we go out once a year
there's a week where we go door to door
and we ask people to invite us into
their homes so that we can check their
smoke detectors first of all do they
have an adequate number and the ones
that they have are they working if not
the fire
uh fighters will actually
change them out for you
well
they typically would just sort of go
wherever with no particular strategy of
which neighborhood to go to they would
go when they had some time during that
week whatever they were sort of closest
to so the question was is there a better
way to do that
and so you can already begin to see some
of the ethical issues of just doing it
where you are
and so they gave us the data that they
had for a few years of where they went
in the county and what they found and we
were able to take that and put a machine
learning model together
and actually map out and we were able to
match that up with other things like
how old the housing units were other
different socioeconomic
um
indicators
across the county you know again at
these different locations on a census
block group basis
and we were actually able to build a
model a predictive model that told them
where they would have the highest
percentage
of homes that perhaps were in need of
their help
now that in and of itself is also a bit
of an ethical issue
because
is it fair to just go to the red areas
here or should they really be spreading
out across the entire county
so we were able to provide them this
information and then encourage them to
do a mix of where they were going and
then in the next year they you know gave
us they went out and also provided the
data back and we were really pleased
that our model actually did quite well
and we were able to provide them an even
um you know better updated set of
information of what the status looked
like across the county
so with that
this brings us to the last question
in our data acumen
set of questions and i'm going to turn
it over to stephanie at this point
thank you sally um
that sets the stage nicely for
moving on to our data science framework
i'm going to introduce our data science
framework our community engagement
process and then a case study that
demonstrates the power of data acumen
from the beginning to the end of the
project much as sally does did but in a
slightly different approach
so to address our data science problems
for the public good we've developed this
data science framework to guide our
processes
and it provides for us a comprehensive
and rigorous way for doing data science
i like to think about it as having three
main components so you have
communications and dissemination on the
left you have the analytics in the
middle and then you have your ethics and
recently we've been thinking about
adding ethics and equity review on the
right-hand thing on the right-hand side
and all three are essential to achieving
the data acumen um and they're also
intertwined and the reason for the two
bars along the side is that we are doing
that at every stage of the analytics
process
so the analytics
component emphasizes working in
collaboration with our consumers sally's
talked about that a lot um but the
important thing here is that we're
trying to develop a shared understanding
of the context of what are the real
questions that they
want and we're trying to do that in a
way that is focused unbiased research
questions as the first step and i i like
to say that this is often the hardest
part of the project because defining um
seemingly clear and unbiased questions
is challenging as you all know
um but it's achieved through our
conversations with stakeholders the
consumers the experts and of course a
review of the literature as well
and then throughout the process we are
always uh communicating both internally
with the team as well as sharing our
results externally because of course
that's where you get your feedback and
we also are also seeking feedback about
the ethical dimensions along the way so
it's an iterative process that's why
there's the circle in the middle um so
it's not a linear process at all but
each step informs the other both prior
and and going forward and what i love
about our data science framework is that
it really helps you say okay we've
defined these clear questions now what's
next and
going through our data discovery our
data ingestion and governance the
wrangling of the data and then our
statistical modeling and analysis and
fitness for use
so next slide sally
and then along with our data science
framework we've um through working many
problems with many communities we've
developed a community engagement process
and again it the community participates
in asking and answering questions i
think that's really uh part of the
beauty of this process is building their
capacity to do that to know that they
they have the power uh to ask and get
answers to these questions and work with
us to develop those answers as well
um and so looking at this wheel
the outer wheel is the continuous
interaction and communications across
stakeholders and communities
and then the middle wheel is more of the
data learning process as we
have defined
you know you're you you know you start
by
you're working with the community to
discover today the data to integrate the
data to act on those measure and then
and evaluate and then redirect so that's
why you know the continuous cycle and
then the frontier between the two
uh represents the active collaboration
between all partners and then of course
in the middle um is our rigorous data
science framework that guides the data
science work
next slide sally
so now i want to present an end-to-end
example of posing and answering the data
accurate questions similar to what sally
did um as you know
as well as integrating that with our
community engaged that process in
describing that process as it unfolds um
next slide
so the road this is going to be about
the roanoke valley allegheny region and
it's a beautiful region it has five
counties and three cities in western
virginia and sort of the anchor is the
city of roanoke it has a population of
about 300 000 a little over 300 000
people and an unemployment rate of 2.8
percent and it is predominantly white
although it is um that number keeps
dropping um but not
not as low as what we saw in arlington
um next slide
so we worked with the roanoke valley
allegheny region commission i'm just
going to refer to them as the commission
throughout and they are the consumer in
this case
um and they are one of 21 planning
commissions in virginia and so we asked
them you know what is what is the
problem you want to solve and what are
your questions um next slide
and what they were interested in was
building a workforce um they said to us
you know we have dozens of universities
around us within you know 25 50 miles
yet only five percent of the graduates
actually stay in our region how do we
attract them um to stay
you know and and become product you know
have their families here um
have you know work work in the labor
force enroll in the roanoke region
and so that led us we thought actually
when they initially asked us the
question we were going to do a very much
labor market kind of analysis um but
when they started talking about what
what would it take to attract
experienced workers um from other
regions as well as to keep the recent
graduates we realized that that was the
question that we wanted to ask what are
the factors that make an area attractive
to workers and families and what
challenges does the region face so the
next slide sally
so what kind of decisions need to be
made
the next step was to see if we could
frame this issue to develop a strategic
plan they were interested in a
developing a strategy that would help
them make their region more attractive
to attract workers
both singles and families
so we first looked at what other
communities were doing we also explained
explored with the commission how to
frame their question in the data context
so next slide sally
um
so we asked what kinds of data do you
have available and why should i trust
the data
and part of our process of course is
always to understand the quality of the
data and that helps us understand and
trust it as well
next slide
so what we did was we sat down with the
commission and created a data map and
this is a great tool for developing sort
of a conceptual understanding
of the project and gets both you know
the consumer and and the researchers
working together and really rolling up
their sleeves to say okay what is it
that we're trying to address so we did
in fact focus on the behavior in the
labor force and we decided that there
were some internal labor force
challenges and external labor force
challenges
that we were looking at so on the
internal labor force side we looked at
things such as drug use and prisoner
re-entry and child care costs
and others things like internal issues
such as access to training and the
ability to earn certificates
and then we also wanted to look at
factors that were external to the labor
force so things about you know are
primarily focused on the community so
how nice is it to live in the region are
there parks is it walkable are there
cultural events and what about public
transportation and commuting how hard is
it to commute
that we did know was one of the
challenges in the area as well
so in the middle of this data map is um
you know the households and the labor
force comes out of the households and of
course there's the eight cities or five
five counties and three cities that make
up the whole region
and they're primarily concerned with the
workforce development and attracting
industry as well as
families to support jobs in that
industry as well
next slide sally
so we undertook a data discovery process
and the data map definitely helped us
guide that data discovery because we saw
the kinds of data we wanted now we need
to look and understand or or it's a
process that we under undertake um to
see what's out there what what data are
out there in the wild that might inform
our our
pro our project or a problem we don't
just rely on the data that we are
familiar with we really like to do this
exploratory stage because we uncover
some really interesting sources of data
that help or help inform the research
and provide new insights into addressing
the research questions
so we when we do that
next slide
um we actually undertake some what we
call just descriptive analysis to begin
looking at what these data sources look
like and this is just a little bit some
of the data that we were examining we
use multiple sources of data always the
traditional american community survey
but also data from the us department of
education the virginia employment
commission cdc and just many many other
sources as you can see
and what's useful about this step is not
just the data discovery but we also
begin to learn about the issues facing
the region so we learned about there was
food insecurity and obesity there's low
population growth and there's changes in
income and unemployment so all of that
can affect how attractive a region
region is
um next slide
and then we also wanted to use some
place-based data as well
so one of the things because we knew
transportation was a challenge
we map public transportation car
ownership and proximity to
training sites or other services such as
drug treatment facilities
and we discovered that most of those
facilities were primarily located in the
roanoke the city of roanoke versus just
closely related to that and so if you
lived you know in one of the counties it
was further to get there and
transportation is definitely an issue
especially for a lot of the workers and
so that was one of the problems that we
identified and just being able to map
that data um you know looking at the
public transportation as well as the car
ownership you can see that you know
getting to these sites is uh probably
you have to have a car a car that's
going to work and get you there um so
anyway that that obviously lays the um
basis for some policy actions there as
well
um next slide
uh so the next question uh we asked is
what's the type of the analysis that
we're going to be doing
and we can go on to the next slide
so what we wanted to do was to explore
with the commission what might be useful
metrics and how might we integrate
these data and recall they had talked
about attractiveness
and how they were interested in using
data to tell how attractive their region
is both the singles and both the
families we can go on to the next slide
and so in this slide what we did was we
created these composite indicators using
uh some synthetic data that we had
created from the american community
survey and local property data and then
we mapped it by magisterial districts
and those are voting districts
essentially but we live in the
commonwealth of virginia so they call
them magisterial districts but we did
that at a sub-county subsidy level to
approximate neighborhoods so that we're
getting down and we can actually study
different parts of the county or
different parts of the city
and what we can see actually when we
look at these composites which were
composed of data for about
transportation housing and then the
community
is that the day you know singles are
very different than families
um singles are more interested in living
in urban environments so that means
they're more likely to live around the
city of roanoke while families are more
likely to live or be spread more out
throughout the
throughout the region and that might
be you know they want larger homes or
more yard or the schools depending on
you know the quality of the schools and
the different areas as well
so this provided a tremendous amount of
insight um into
in for for the commission to begin to
able begin to think about what kind of
policies that they wanted to think about
so i did i think i forgot to add that
the lighter the color the more
attractive is the area so that's
obviously for the singles the lighter
the color here and the light of the
color for families you can see where
they were interested in living in
so we worked with the next slide
we worked with the commission because we
were also concerned about the ethical
issues about our research
and we had conversations with the
commission with
the county and city planners the service
providers and just people in different
parts of the region
and there was a lot of sensitivity about
drug rehabilitation and prisoner
re-entry into the community and
workforce and they were just concerned
that that might define their region as
not being attractive but the commission
decided that these issues were too
important to ignore and that policies
are needed to support the populations so
it still provided motivation that they
needed to address the issues broadly
but also focused in on training and some
of the other issues as well because
these um a lot of this leads to of
course a potential workforce that would
would populate that
um so what they did was uh i guess we
just went through this slide but this go
goes back of course to get back to
each of um our data science checklist
where at each stage you know again to
reiterate we assess our research
questions our data sources our models
for implicit biases we had lots of
conversations with stakeholders
i talked about the sensitivity about
certain groups and decided that these
were too important to ignore
next slide
so we were
pleased to see that in the following
year when they developed their
strategies that they had addressed many
of the issues
that we had pointed out through our
composite indicators as well as looking
at the individual composites as well
that made up and you can see they really
they actually align quite nicely with
how we created the data and the
indicators
they did say that when they had worked
with
other groups before like one group had
given them a list of 100 indicators that
they could use to track
like progress in their region and they
just said it was overwhelming and so
they found the use of these composites
really helpful and then creating you
know these maps that a sub a lower
geography than just counties and cities
that they could actually understand the
different areas
was enormously helpful to them
so let's uh last slide sally
so to wrap up this
summarizes a lot of what you heard today
data science as we know is foundational
to our economy and lives and we are
passionate about requiring or not
requiring but
teaching people are building capacity
especially communities
especially with about their level of
data acumen and that allows them to make
good judgments about the use of data to
support their problem solutions that is
our definition as sally noted
um but understanding the basics of data
science and data acumen not only allows
us to work with communities but allows
them to build their capacity to ask
questions use data and to make data
informed
data informed decisions
so at the heart of our work is our data
science framework and our cld3 our
community learning through data-driven
discovery process
and that integrates our communications
and ethics you know across the
analytical
analytical parts of the projects
and these processes they help us to
accelerate accelerate our work and then
importantly for us it also helps us just
identify our next steps so you know as
we go through the process it's a guide
to help us and a reminder to incorporate
ethics and communications and
dissemination into our work
so both are a scaffold also that allows
us to document our work in a transparent
way
so um
we think that it's really important and
you can tell that we're passionate about
incorporating ethics into our research
and
we hope you found this useful
thank you
sally and stephanie thank you so much
that was a
wonderful overview i really enjoyed
hearing about your data science
framework that looks like a very useful
tool for kind of solving you know
identifying a problem and identifying
data and going through a process of
iterating on that to come up with
solutions
um one of the things that i noticed that
um sally had shown is uh
the belmont report and for those of us
in biomedical science if you've ever had
to do any irb training the belmont
report is something that we all know
about the thing i thought was a little
bit ironic about sally's slide is that
the cut the the picture that you showed
of the belmont report comes from the for
forgotten books collection
which i thought was rather interesting
because
clearly the belmont report has given
rise to um many other things the menlo
report i wasn't very aware of um
but i was also interested maybe you
could discuss a little bit about how the
evolution of these kind of ethical
principles that were embodied in the
belmont report in the common rule before
that and now the menlo report how this
dovetails with data openness and open
science
team science and how those that interact
with data ethics and the considerations
thereof
so steph i'm going to punt that one to
you
okay stephanie if you can answer that
one
so let me rephrase the question and make
sure that i understand it because i was
thinking sally was going to take this
[Laughter]
so the um thinking about sort of the
belmont report and then the continuum
along with
the
menlo report and how that integrates
with sort of all the facets of data
science including team science i mean i
think it it definitely in open science
and all of that i think that it
definitely raises awareness um and
issues about you know what the
challenges are in data science
especially when you are integrating data
and a lot of times uh on the surface
it may seem that you're taking data
sources that are
um
just transparent or that you can use
because they seem to be publicly
available but there is a lot of concern
about you know you take your cell phone
data and you combine it with your
twitter data and then all of a sudden
you you marry it with the local property
data like you know can you begin to
identify people or does it bring does it
highlight certain groups in a way that
you may not that
is not positive or in a way that doesn't
contribute to the conversation and so
the menlo report spends a lot of time
talking about like some of the
challenges or things that can happen
when you begin to integrate the data
so i guess those are the challenges that
you might have to address when you're
looking at open source data or we're
also just working as a team on that
so i'm sure that sally can probably
answer that
more cohesive way
i think that the i you one of the things
that we found um
interesting when we when we started
our research group and when we started
you know working on these problems um
with computer scientists data you know
now called data scientists and with the
communities is that a lot of computer
scientists and data scientists who uh
you know
that are out there working different
problems
they're not aware of an irb they don't
go through that training like jack you
and others in the biomedical field have
done
um that that's that's just not part of
what they've had to do they haven't had
to think of their data that way we've
really been encouraging
more of that to take place
um and the other thing that is
interesting to us is that as we've been
working with communities because we work
with a lot of local governments and
local communities
that's not in their vernacular either
that that's just not part of what they
worry about even though they're knitting
together all of this data about you know
people places the economy
and so i think it's really useful to
have something like this ethics
checklist that we that we've talked
about that we've developed
and with your
partners with your sponsors
part of the project team that you you
all go through some of this together and
have these discussions
and to the question that caitlyn asked
about
why do we think the menlo report hasn't
really been taken up by data scientists
that's one of our big mysteries we don't
know because it was sort of developed by
this team of computer scientists now
perhaps uh we don't have all the ins and
outs of why or how the department of
homeland security asked for it but i
will say in a in addition to the report
that nicole has linked you to in the
chat there's also a follow-up where they
do some case studies and we can find
that and share that with you it's it's
pretty fascinating and we wish that more
people would focus in on some of these
things
i know i always think about one of these
days i just want to pick up the phone or
send an email to all those computer
scientists and say what happened you
know
why is this probably buried
probably isn't the first time it won't
be the last time that some you know
commissioned report sort of
didn't really catch fire but um but it's
interesting and again i didn't wasn't
very aware of it um hopefully some of
our data science colleagues will now be
inspired to go and look at it and see
how it maps onto some of the work that
they're doing um in particular i noticed
that after you guys have you know you've
scoped out what the problem is and then
you start asking about the availability
of data so that you can kind of go
through a mapping operation of how does
that data map onto your problem
what are some of the things that you
look for in order to be able to trust
that that data is valid it's showing you
what it's you know it says it's a
measure is it really measuring what it
says it's measuring how do you trust it
how do you know that it's sufficiently
large enough to represent the catchment
area of you know of the county that
you're trying to map
what are some of those things that you
guys consider
so so jack first i'd say that you know
we have a pretty uh structured process
the data discovery process that we've
developed over the over the years
and it starts by you know kind of
getting the team together and just
encouraging people to open their mind
and their imaginations
and make a wish list if they have if you
could have any data
under the sun
to help support the problem that you're
working on what would you want
and to just start writing that down
don't worry about if it exists or not
just write it down
and then once we do that we
develop a screening process
where we're going to now start to go see
if we can find any of these sources
but we'll have screening questions so
that we don't waste too much time trying
to go after some data if it's not going
to meet the
time frame some of the variables that
might be relevant here so we actually
you know put a screening tool together
to help screen the different sources
and you know in one of them
you know one element of the screening
tool would be you know in what time
frame might i be able to develop the
data sharing agreement for this data
because if it's going to take three
years and my problem i have to get done
in a year it's not going to be helpful
so so we sort of so we have this sort of
formal process but then as we get the
data as we start acquiring the data
um
you know we really do worry about
fitness for use and fitness for use is
a function of
how the data is going to feed into a
model or an analysis
as well as how complete the data are
and so we worry a lot and we have
conversations around coverage and bias
who's
left out of this data do i even can i
even tell who might be left out of this
data
and the acknowledgement of that is
really important because it's we may
still use it but at least we acknowledge
and we have documented what the
limitations are in the interpretation of
whatever analyses come out of this
and also it's important to note that
don't waste time wrangling data that you
might not use i might have a big data
file or a big data set or a big survey
i'm not going to clean it all up i'm
just going to really focus on those
elements and clean them to the point
that i need for the analysis that i'm
going to support and a great example is
we work a lot with housing stock and
housing data and also multiple listing
service data
and in the multiple listing service data
they have hundreds of variables that
they collect
um but they're very it's very uneven the
quality of the data because to a realtor
some data is more important than others
and we have a situation where they
collect zoning codes for their for their
properties
um but
they don't tend to pay a lot of
attention to getting those codes right
and
a lot of what we care about is is it
residential or not and it turns out if
they simply got an r in the in the
zoning code and the rest of the numbers
who cares r meant it was residential so
we could take this incredibly noisy data
rather than throw it out we could get
the dichotomous mapping that we wanted
just by being smart by understanding
what the data quality issues were
and just to add on to that i think the
fitness for use sometimes can be a
simple benchmarking or that can almost
be as creative as the ethics questions
as well on trying to figure out that
often sometimes can be a qualitative
analysis or it can be quantitative if
you have something that you can compare
to but as with all of this it's as much
an art as a science
that's the truth
one thing i noticed um
sally you were mentioning um you're
working with uh you know county level um
first responder data and
uh you noted that um there was no say
continual id that kind of followed
somebody throughout the trajectory of
the thing but you had to start all this
data but i was wondering at what point
that stops and in the sense of the first
responders their measure of success
where okay the victim of the accident
was successfully delivered to the
hospital where they could get further
treatment and then that was that was it
they they checked the box and they're
done but it starts another process at
the level of the hospital where okay
patient is now admitted and then they're
going to go
and so you've got this sort of chain of
data that's you know may start and stop
with one entity then it migrates to the
next one and if only you had that
continuous stream you could actually
measure the efficacy of how the first
responders did did they treat the wound
properly so that treatment could be
affected and the person survived or did
something terrible happen to them when
the first responders didn't do it right
and the person died you know is it that
kind of thing and i was just kind of
commenting or wondering if you could
comment on how these kind of chains of
data might be uh leveraged um in
something like your data science
framework for example
right that's such a great question now
for the first responders
their window into the world ends at the
emergency room yeah you know that they
deliver the patient to the emergency
room and then
they're done
you know and and then you know yet
you're right it would be so wonderful to
be linking this through and learning so
much more and the first responders would
love to do that too
but there's all but there's all
different issues that happen as soon as
it hits the hospital right and yeah but
the one thing that i would say
if we could you know if we could develop
that project
that allows us to cross that chasm it
would be exciting
and
we don't have to worry about having all
these little unique identifiers to link
this data we were able to demonstrate by
having these administrative systems that
were disjoint across this just across
the path of the event of the incident
that we've linked together that we can
be smart data science can help us figure
out how to link the right data together
so if we could just begin to be getting
that you know
emergency room data
we would have you know we would have
different ways we could we could um link
it into the other data without having to
have some big you know data system
developed to do that i guess that's my
point that standardization is not needed
on all of these things data science
helps us get past that
but that would be wonderful i mean that
would be the wonderful thing but that's
again where we hit a hit up against
um
just the hipaa medical side that we
don't hit up against
in the ems data although i think when we
were trying to do this this was like
2014 2015 and things have started to
really change it seems like even
hospitals are becoming more open about
sharing their data as long as it's kept
confidential so
um but we we haven't gone back to try
that yet well i certainly hope that they
do because that that is a wonderful
opportunity for sort of the approach
that you took where you're temporarily
trying to align
these different data types to see if you
can identify correspondence between them
and then allow you to bridge that chasm
otherwise you have this weird
discontinuity that you have to then you
know oh i don't have a identifier at any
rate it sounds like it would be a maybe
tractable kind of thing just being
investigating or maybe in
charlottesville where the hospital's
more willing to share the data than they
are maybe in other other areas as well
maybe maybe in roanoke they're not so
interested i don't know so what is this
arlington but still yeah arlington
arlington one of the things we one of
the things we were able to look at which
was pretty interesting was
when that when an incident when a call
comes in they sort of make an assessment
of what it is
so that they can determine what to
dispatch
right and we actually did have them data
of what they thought it was and what it
was you know when their window into it
ended
and those things didn't
line up quite as well as they had
expected which is really useful
information to the fire chief right they
have to make quick decisions and then
when they arrive it's often something
different i can imagine you know
somebody's oh yeah my my arm hurts oh
okay you did something to your arm and
then it turns out oh no it's a heart
attack right
like obviously you would have taken them
to maybe a different location if you had
known that yeah all sorts of interesting
data challenges well
sally and stephanie thank you so much
for sharing your um your process with us
and uh several really interesting
examples that i think you know
even though you the the areas you
focused on were not necessarily
biomedical per se but all of those
general ideas and how one evaluates data
how it goes through your data science
framework process
those are all directly relevant to how
people deal with data from biomedicine
and especially um keeping it ethical and
thinking ethically about how that data
gets used so i want to thank you so much
for sharing your thoughts with us today
i want to thank everybody who joined us
and i want to thank wish everybody a
very happy
friday and do enjoy your weekend we'll
see you all next week have a great
weekend
thank you